Another big piece of the user
experience are notifications.
Notifications allow you to
communicate with the user,
and they can take many different forms,
text messages, emails,
push notifications, icons,
vibrations, banners, and alerts.
You'll need to think carefully about
how often you notify users and
what forms those notifications take,
since they contribute to
the overall user experience.
A graph or matrix like this one can help
you think through the importance and
urgency of your notifications.
As I walk through the upcoming examples,
you should think about
where notifications might
fall on this diagram.
In general, you want to avoid sending
many messages that have low importance
and low urgency.
If you're sending a lot of
these types of messages,
it can make your product feel spammy.
Keep in mind that the frequency for a
given notification may change over time,
and this graph might look different for
different personas using the product.
You should think about
different notifications for
different personas as you
work on your product.
Some might have preferences for
one notification over others.
In general, there's some key
qualities of notifications
that you should keep in mind for
your users.
The first one is control.
And it's the most important thing
that you want to give users.
Little Big Details is a website
that showcases a lot of
awesome user experience.
When it comes to control,
Foursquare in Apple gives users lots
of control through menus like these.
The second is feedback.
Other types of notifications
involve informing the user
about tasks that they are performing.
This is really just about good
design in user experience.
The feedback provided is
dependent on the product.
And by providing great feedback,
you can make users
feel like you're looking out for them
while making the product more usable.
For example, Twitter will try and
provide feedback if you
send the same tweet twice.
Slack, a messaging app also
provides great feedback to users.
It provides a confirmation
when sending a message
to a channel that has people
in different time zones.
And Amazon provides feedback about
whether someone may have bought you
an item on your Wish List.
All of these notifications
are related to feedback loops for
users to successfully complete tasks.
The third is customization.
It's a more subtle aspect of
notifications for your users.
You might do this based on time,
task, location or
some other attribute
that's tied to the user.
Facebook for example, shows a different
part of the world to users,
depending on the user's location.
Finally, you can develop notifications
that lead users to form a habit of using
your product depending on the frequency
and any rewards you might give them.
You can tap into what Nir Eyal
describes as variable rewards.
GitHub provides variable rewards to its
users by showing a different Octocat
each time the user has
no new notifications.
Tumblr sends emails with playful
texts when a user follows someone or
when someone else follows that user.
And, Coffee Meets Bagel,
which is a dating application,
uses digital currency to reward users
for tapping into the dating app.
Each of these qualities contributes
to the user experience and
their perception of your product.